what's the hallmark of a great script
how do you know you want to choose that
one over the thousands or hundreds of
others that you look at what
uh personal or personal and usually i
don't read other people's scripts and i
usually develop something or
um i have something in mind and i work
with a friend usually in uh some cases
nick pelagi in other cases jaycox and
uh or hire paul schroeder for uh
bringing out the dead but but for
example when taxi driver was given to me
to read by brian de palma
um i haven't done main streets yet and
so but he said you'd be great for this
and automatically i mean there had to be
an emotional connection
to the material into the characters
um the obsessiveness of travis pickle
but certainly taxi driver when you got
that i said this this one has to be made
and we just knew it but first of all sd
i remember there's notes from
underground that was taxi driver really
so
you know i say i feel like that that's
me you know that sort of thing so really
really identify with it